so this is just a brief reminder
property rights consists of a bundle of
Rights both use rights and management or
decision making right and the furthest
reaching rights are those to alienation
or transfer so the right your hand a
resource to others either by inheritance
or by selling it and very often natural
resources are restricted so the rights
that people have over natural resources
are restricted in one or other way just
let me know if there's any questions on
just I'm just assuming you you've heard
about this know this but if it's not the
case do let me know now basically the
right established relationship not from
me to the resource but rather between me
and everyone else in society because
it's only mine if everyone else agrees
it's mine that I have these and hold
these right now in many countries we
have a pluralism of different systems
and and options of recognizing like the
rights that might be overlapping and
often also competing so they go reach
all the way from international treaties
and laws of a state law to religious law
customary law which may be opposing to
the previous mentioned once and it goes
all the way down to organizational loss
of user groups if you live in a
condominium somewhere there might be a
whole set of rules going up to the color
of your curtains that I established by
the group and have no no legal basis but
nonetheless apply so basically this
means or not not necessarily this but
goods can be provided in different
formats either as private Goods where
others can be excluded as public goods
with this is not the case and as all as
common property where group
of users share rights and collectively
manage and enjoy the benefits of
resource so you've seen this one what
I'd like you to briefly think about and
then tell me is what happens to the
rights in these different situations if
a value or a value is recognized an
ecosystem value is recognized in society
who holds the rights and in what form it
you think of an example of recognized
value
yeah who was right there
established in that case by national law
and the fact that we call it recognized
value kind of leads to the fact that it
is these property rights are recognized
why at least most of the society which
as I said earlier in circumstances of
overlapping regimes might not be the
case might customarily be an area where
population has been living and people
have been using the forest and they
might challenge that but how about the
situation of demonstrating value what's
the right situation they are usually if
we feel the need to demonstrate a value
like a personal or user right
thinking of like in a case where we need
to demonstrate the value of a ecosystem
service that's not being properly
included in decision-making the rights
that's going to be a tension between the
rights of the people who might own that
resource and the rights of the group at
large who benefit from the service so I
guess different
yeah typically in situations where we
want to demonstrate value there it's the
right situation is not so clear and for
many ecosystem services that are under
provisioned or that as yet not clearly
defined rights are not defined yet so
the aspect of scenic beauty is something
we we value but there's not much
definition of that usually there might
be some building codes that do recognize
it but and how about the situation of
capturing value
baby payments for ecosystem services for
example what happens with the rights
they're providing so the moment we start
capturing a value we are also defining a
right if we have a PS scheme we define
that the person who is providing the
service has a right to compensation as
right to be rewarded to this we could
also pass a rule and say you need to
provide this this is a legal obligation
then the right would be with the society
to have this or to maintain this so the
milk the moment we establish a mechanism
to capture value in implicitly or
explicitly wanting to or not we
establish a property right is that a
question
now I'm saying when we establish a
mechanism to capture the value which
might before that be there but we're not
aware of it or we we haven't calculated
it or only some people are aware of it
at the moment we establish a mechanism
to capture it we introduce mechanisms
that will incorporate the value into
decision-making we be advised pas scheme
beard via an offset system or whatever
we at the same time established property
rights and most people are not aware of
that so a lot of the debate on should
someone be allowed or not allowed is
because it establishes rights and it
puts people in two different positions
afterwards okay we'll come back to that
in some of the examples so on the
poverty no one has talked to you about
GDP of the poor in my correct or has
someone touched that some other lecture
seems it was mentioned okay so basically
what are deeply and and parvin did was
we calculate GDP by the ecosystem
service contribution to GDP and also
looking at who benefits from this so
these first these first values refer to
the value of ecosystem services within
classical gdp for these three countries
you know the millions for their for now
and it mainly covers agriculture
forestry fisheries so the directly
resource dependent contributions to GDP
now what they did was look at how much
of this goes to poor people and that
those are the the values up there this
is the population of people depending
heavily on ecosystem service poorer
people depending heavily on ecosystem
services and then they calculated which
part of agriculture forestry and
Fisheries goes to the limbs of it's
mainly for dwellers smallholder farmers
artisanal fishermen fishermen and also
calculated the value of products that
are usually not marketed like non-timber
forest products or fuel wood and the
like that comes directly from ecosystem
services as well as some of the
regulating services like flood
protection for example and then for
these amount of people that were
identified as highly dependent the
percentage of ecosystem services to
their GDP so to their income and
well-being is much much higher reaching
75% 4789 so this is an aggregate way of
measuring and demonstrating the
importance of ecosystem services for
poorer segments of society now we go
into agriculture as an example of
natural resource management and some
general numbers 2.6 billion people
relying on agricultural production
systems for their livelihoods 525
million small farms worldwide out of
which 404 million less than two hectares
and in total small farms cultivate sixty
percent of arable land now interesting
is this increase if we have the ten
percent increase in farm yields we can
expect seven percent reduction in
poverty in Africa and still more than
five percent in Asia so the dependence
of poorer households on agriculture is
quite high and what we've also
increasingly
seen over the last decades and it's been
increasingly demonstrated is that green
farming practices have increased yields
especially on small farms to a
considerable degree so after the Green
Revolution took care of the easily
arable lands and the under under good
conditions we see that there are plenty
of usually ecosystem service enhancing
practices that can also help increase
smallholder yields in summary an
increase in overall GDP coming from
agricultural labor productivity is on
average 2.5 times more effective in
raising the income of the lowest
quintile lowest income quintile in
developing country then an equivalent
increase in GDP coming from non
agricultural labor productivity so if
you want to do something about poverty
it's worthwhile to invest in increasing
agricultural labour productivity now
what's the situation in agriculture we
have very broadly speaking to general
pathways that are problematic for both
are problematic for ecosystem services
we have intensive agriculture
characterized by high levels of
pollution eg from fertilizers or
pesticides soil erosion and
deterioration especially soil carbon
being being reduced and biodiversity
suffers at all levels ecosystems species
and genetic with evermore increasing
specialized farm production on the other
hand we have extensive agriculture
usually in the not so favorable
conditions which leads to an ongoing
process of deforestation usually we have
problems of soil mining nutrient
depletion especially when on slopes also
problems of erosion
so both both development of Agriculture
are problematic to ecosystem services
but there's quite a bit we can do about
this the central challenge being
increase yield while not decreasing or
even better while increasingly other
ecosystem services involved okay now one
easy way of fostering this from a policy
point of view is organic agriculture why
because in the concept of organic
agriculture it includes ecosystem
services especially soil management and
maintenance in its very concept and
therefore it is an ecosystem service
conscious way of of improving or working
in agriculture and here's an example
from the green you cannot economy
initiative and reports from Uganda that
actually there has been considerable
growth in organic agriculture over the
past couple of years in impressively
increasing exports and this has had co
benefits of lower carbon emission and
possibly even saw carbon sequestration
that thus a contribution to climate and
in general provides a business
opportunity as most of the producers
although I'd say not not necessarily
quite as high amounts of production I in
developing countries whereas most of the
demand is in our acct countries okay
further policy options for enhancing
ecosystem services in intensive
agriculture well most developed
countries have quite a bit quite a set
of different a growing environmental
schemes you have them here in the US we
certainly have them in Europe and they
have been enhanced in the reform of our
agricultural policy
at least in Europe but I imagine it must
may be similar here this comes with
rules of cross compliance so if you
receive subsidies for agro environmental
schemes on part of your farm you need to
comply with some basic rules of
protecting the environment on the rest
of your part of your farm as well some
countries such as Germany for example
also regulate this directly so a certain
level of technology is is mandated by
regulation you can't just go about and
use far too much fertilizer if that's
not state of Technology then you are you
against the law of course this is
difficult to enforce what it sets it
said certain cutoff lines you can go
about rewarding less damaging practices
this is what Agri environmental schemes
basically do you can also do this by
reverse auctions I'll come to an example
in a minute regarding biodiversity you
can foster interruption of large fields
EG by creating corridors by having
hedges by having connecting landscape
elements that will allow the ecosystem
service at the ecosystem to maintain
part of its and integrity and its
habitat qualities my may also be
decisive for maintaining pollination
services and the like you can improve
the technology and knowledge of the
people who are managing and working in
agriculture like applying just the right
amount of fertilizer because ultimately
it's also not in their interest that
there is a lot of runoff and there are
options to maintain Jin genetic
diversity for example also in Seto so
there's in the chapter 5 of the D to
report there is a example of the sea
rise initiative in the Philippines where
they maintained local varieties and
improve them with local
Obama's rice varieties making them less
dependent from on international seed
companies but also providing options for
adapting varieties to local
circumstances okay so here comes the
example this is from Pennsylvania to
reduce phosphorus loads in Conestoga
watershed so basically what they did was
apply so called reverse auctions so
farmers could bid and say what they
would be wanting to receive as
compensation for applying best
management practices for phosphorus
management then they used a tool the
nutrient net tool provided by the world
Research Institute to determine the
phosphorus reduction of the different
management practices farmers place bids
of prices they are willing to accept for
specific measures these bids were ranked
according to the costs of saved
phosphorus until the budget available
for these options was exhausted and they
found out that this allowed them to
achieve the goal of reducing phosphorus
by approximately half what they had been
with conventional cost share subsidy
schemes this approach was also piloted
in USDA wetlands management program to
reduce the cost of acquiring wetland
easement so this is a policy instrument
if you don't want to go about set by
subsidies that that will set a level
price for everyone but want to make use
of the fact that some farmers will be
able to provide certain management
practice or apply it at much lower costs
this is one policy option to do this and
again I'll use this slide which has a
slightly different message again with
this we are establishing property rights
so by the fact that we say we pay
farmers to use less phosphorus they are
granted the right to use and apply as
much phosphorus as they feel like and
society is willing to compensate this
and pay them in order to reduce what
they do and thereby reduce the damage to
the water and supply the ecosystem
services of the water quality regulation
for example so basically this this graph
shows different levels of Environmental
Policy and depending on the types of
instruments we're using we are granting
the right to one or the other party to
either be obliged not to pollute or to
be compensated for not polluting an
example for the more extensive type of
settings from this case from India
setting of low rainfall increasing
deforestation that led to increasing
runoff decline of water level till the
point was reached when only twelve
percent of arable land could be could be
farmed due to water scarcity and high
levels of out-migration where the result
they then started regenerating degraded
forests and and building contour bonds
and contour trenches using two different
government schemes that were providing
some incentives for villages to improve
their situation and also an Employment
Guarantee Scheme and by this were able
to double in a short time period of only
seven years the wells that had water
again in the areas under irrigation also
brass and consequently milk production
in poverty was reduced by seventy-three
percent people returning in the labs of
say twenty years what is interesting
also about this case is that they have a
very strict water management
so together with water management
authorities added on a yearly basis the
the amount of available water is
determined then water is set aside for
domestic and livestock use the rest
seventy percent goes to irrigation with
obligations to what crops can or cannot
be cropped depending on water
availability and the remaining is
calculated to recharge groundwater
another example from Columbia pass where
pasture degradation was resulting in
income loss and for the expansion of
pasture area also it's affecting forest
area the challenge was how to tackle
this poor pasture practices and with
them the problems of soil erosion and
water run oven biodiversity loss now by
improving through silver pastoral
management improving planting improved
grasses but also photo shrubs and for
and entries a GF funded project was able
to to recover three and a half thousand
hectares and what they did was pay
initially for for biodiversity and
carbon fixation this allowed to cover
the initial investment costs and some of
the results were that after the project
moved out and the the payment scheme
stopped nonetheless farmers still kept
up the practices because the local
benefits it was providing at that point
of being established and and we're we're
high enough to to enable them to
maintain it and the maintenance costs
okay now
forestry very briefly you know this
better than I do some of the challenges
it's a long-term investment payoffs it
pays off only well into the future a lot
of people especially small holder
farmers are often not able to incur
these costs in many countries thats also
cumbersome might not be the right word
but complicated due to regulation I just
came back from from a stay in Thailand
where they've all but band forestry from
their forests and if you want to fail
trees on private lands you need a permit
for felling the tree then you need
another permit for moving it from A to B
and you and then you needed need wanted
to sell the products etc it's become
very complicated this basically dates
back to the time when they had abundant
forests and the state wanted to
participate in all the income this was
generating but now it's it's practically
preventing any any timber industry from
happening aside from rubber and pulp
production in low rotation trees because
both of these are not considered for us
but agriculture and don't fall under
this regulation in many places it's also
not competitive with alternative land
uses nonetheless it has enormous co
benefits in terms of biodiversity in
terms of habitat in terms of water in
terms of carbon so it offers a huge
potential for pierre schemes along all
of these lines and when establishing
schemes there's of course also the
possibility to influence what and how is
being planted so to influence what type
of forests we're looking at replacing
monocultural plantation type forest by
more very forest where benefits are much
higher one poverty relevant example from
tanzania applying the six steps we
introduced last time
in this woodland area trees in woodland
where to a large extent cleared this was
to eradicate that city fly create land
and space for agriculture and cash
cropping but they were reaching a point
where where goods and services of trees
and woodlands considered vital
especially to agro pastoralists in the
region but also to other members of the
royal society were disappearing
specifying which ecosystem services were
relevant well a lot of provisioning
services from fuel over building
material to medicine and fodder
especially for dry season and water
provisioning and erosion reduction as
well as cultural value so they resorted
mainly to traditional knowledge on
woodland management because there had
been a tradition of enclosures
especially for fodder reserves that they
were able to revive and that was
recognized then as the basis for forest
restoration and a good opportunity to
involve people directly and produce
exactly those services that were needed
changes could then be assessed sometimes
in terms of time required to obtain
certain services but also in the form of
improved water quality and for the
availability especially in dry season so
this has been a long-term project but by
resorting to the traditional level pipe
yeah building on traditional knowledge
and and costumes it was able it was an
empowering a approach that created local
people's ownership and enhance their
capacity to manage their resources so
approximately 500,000 hectares have been
restored so far across quite a few
income has improved almost doubled in
many of these and the process is now
being spread to at least two further
regions in Tanzania okay so this was
didn't involve valuation beyond
appraising with people what they found
important and what they wanted to
restore the next example does involve an
extensive evaluation study this is from
Indonesia an area where a national park
and surrounding woodlands were heavily
affected especially by the Indonesian
army that got involved in a lot of
illegal logging and the National Park
director commissioned this this study in
order to show an illustrator the
benefits from from conservation and
Peter fanboy cooling and his team did
this study and valued the 11 different
services for three different unison
areas and you can see that for all but
the non-timber forest products the
agriculture and the timber services the
conservation has higher benefits than me
to others and what they also looked into
is the distribution of these benefits to
five different groups out of which two
are presented here one being the local
communities of the people living in the
area and then the logging but not a
really logging industry large companies
using these resources and you can see
that of course the the best scenario for
the industry is the deforestation
scenario whereas for local communities
it's the conservation scenario where
especially through erosion and
landslides protection fire protection
water availability the benefits from
conservation higher
do you know enough about this particular
case to elaborate on the difference
between the conservation and select
abuse the conservation is basically no
use of the area in the natural path and
some use in the area surrounding where
the selected use allows particularly in
our table forest products to be used in
some conversion of land so conservation
didn't have any non-timber forest
products or no yeah I don't know what
exactly this includes but it's hardly
any whereas the selective use does allow
quite a bit and that's that's a typical
issue in national parks buddy if if they
are set up many manager things this
means don't touch anything whereas
particularly non-timber forest products
if managed sustainably which of course
has its its ifs and needs careful
management could well be used without
destroying most of the other functions
and then if we look at this these
benefits over time we can also clearly
see that of course the deforestation
provides benefits much quicker and the
conservation benefits kick in mainly
over time and an interesting anecdote
that when I heard Peters telling this
example himself was when they first
presented these results to the regional
government they really had serious
problems and conveying and they were
very impressed by these numbers and and
yeah the immediate conclusion was well
if it's so valuable let's use it right
away so they didn't at all understand
the concept of the value being in the
conservation and this of course leads to
the typical situation who has the
political lobby of course much more the
logging industry than
local community and of course much more
the short term benefit over the long
term but benefit so actually achieving a
conservation situation is is quite a
challenge and immediately after the the
study it didn't happen in fact the
European Union that had been financing
part of the National Park pulled out
because because policy was not willing
to to support and only recently with a
new election of Governor in this
province a more greener
development-oriented policy has been put
in place and there's some hope this
might change in the future so there's
been a lot of discussion on
co-management collaborative management
especially also in forestry but also in
fisheries to achieve poverty reduction
and sustainability he has some of
summarized results from the source book
that I put up in the reading list I
don't know of any you who had a chance
to to look into it it may seem very
picturesque and very basic for Yale MSC
course what I really like about it is
that it summarizes a huge body of
literature and a whole field of
Investigation that that is quite
recognized at the very latest through
the Nobel Prize to to lynn ostrom two
years ago and it summarizes in 23 pages
each time certain natural resource
management issues with particular
attention to property rights and
collective action and gives you at the
end the relevant literature of really
the scholars that have been doing the
groundbreaking breaking work there so
while being written for practitioners
it's also a very useful reference to get
an overview and to find the relevant
literature on these on these topics so
co-management has improved the former
access to forests where very often
formerly this was state property people
were not allowed to go in there
nevertheless they were living there they
were using these
horses but under very difficult right
situation co-management has in most
cases improved the situation however the
benefits are mainly the ones for
subsistence and as a safety net so
providing resources in lean season for
example whereas in most cases government
has maintained control over the more
valuable resources and has influenced
which trees to plant which of course
opens the possibility to have a more
ecosystem service oriented approach but
if it's centrally governed may also lead
to far from optimal conditions and often
we have a situation of over-regulation
so the access to more valuable
commercial products specially timber
game remains restricted often different
expectations there are from different
expectations from the state on the one
hand and local people on the other hand
very trivially but not always taken into
account not all local people are
actually interested in forest management
so several schemes have also failed you
to this and better sharing mechanisms
are needed both between state and
community as well as within communities
in many settings the the general
conclusion is to build more on local
practices and increase the right of
self-determination which of course may
again be in certain traders with
biodiversity conservation or yeah
long-term forest benefits especially if
the knowledge used to establish
management does not adequately combine
local and scientific knowledge okay with
this I'd like to come to the
conservation and poverty debate so here
are I'm just going to briefly try and
summarize this is an ongoing debate for
at least
20 25 years and seen many changes from
integrated commute conservation and
development and yeah parks with fences
parks without fences etc what I was
trying to say with the not interested
forest community is that there's not
much point but we see this happening
again and again that you have some kind
of a successful recipe for some things
of communal forest to community
management in northern Guatemala has
been very successful then maybe someone
close just tries to copy this without
ever even checking is there this
traditional relationship of the people
to the forest are they actually
interested in forest management or is
their interest actually in getting their
income from somewhere else or in moving
out so that's just the it sounds trivial
but it really happens again and again
that these very trivial things are not
taken into account now of course I mean
that this is a very difficult balance to
strike especially in this whole poverty
set up almost all countries that have
been in involved in agricultural land
reform or in subsidized housing or in
forest plot allocation or whatever
especially to combat poverty have set up
rules where usually they give people
access to the resource under certain
conditions and it's usually not full set
of rights usually at least the right to
transfer in the sense of selling
sometimes even in the sense of
inheriting but certainly lessons of
selling is precluded because they don't
want people to sell out and others to
benefit from government subsidized
resources and then poor people moving
out to something else nonetheless in
most settings it still happens because
poor people off do get into situations
where they have to or they don't have
the capacity to manage the resource
because they might not have access to
credit or two to the knowledge needed or
whatever so this is a difficult
balance to strike and it needs a lot of
going into the the detailed context and
finding out okay what are the options
are actually generating income from this
and also generating income well with a
short term and do the people have the
resources the knowledge and everything
available that they need so handing it
over to a login concession of course you
you can say and many countries have
established some sort of offsetting or
some sort of minimal minimal
requirements if forest is logged and and
taken down this needs to be compensated
by replanting some wells or by
protecting or enhancing or or whatever
but usually you will be losing most of
the services unless you start regulating
okay you allowed to selectively long
certain species and you have to maintain
integrity of XYZ in order to keep
providing the rest of the services and
what else were you referring to yep
yeah yeah we look a little bit into that
in the next lecture on the spatial
planning where they are beginning to try
to do this to map ecosystem services
over larger areas in order to then be
able to determine okay if we want to
give a forest concession we we better do
it in these areas and not those other
crucial areas but you're right it
implies a much more it much higher input
with regard to to information and
information management over time also
and and yeah much more careful
enforcement and monitoring but probably
that's what it boils down to because if
you look at the whole set of services
they they usually do have different
special extension different temporal
dynamics and and different implications
with regard to the benefits they are
providing two different sorts of people
but what what has been shown that with
this co-management particularly in
forestry but but also in fisheries there
have been good results in many places if
these conditions work out reasonably be
reasonably well yeah but you need a
close look at add the rights and and the
services in order to to achieve these
okay so some widespread very general
discourses on the relationship between
conservation
and poverty that poverty leads to the
destruction of biodiversity precisely
because people depend on these resources
and have no other no other opportunity
they over use and destroy them on the
other hand there's the contrary
contradicting discourse that traditional
societies and these often imply poorer
poorer people actually ensure the
conservation of biodiversity because
they have been managing the resource
over time in a sustainable way they have
a lot of local knowledge and are well
able of doing so much better than people
coming in from the outside there's also
the storyline that biodiversity
conservation can lead out of poverty by
preserving the resources that poor
people depend on others say they are
interlinked and determine each other so
depending on just how poor people how
much is still there they are able to
maintain it or does degrade others say
they may coincide in time and and space
but actually have nothing to do with
each other and certainly you can find
case that is to uphold any one of these
or almost also any combination of these
and debate has been turning around this
quite a bit now what I'd like to present
here is a summary from a symposium held
last last year in April by the
Zoological Society of London that
Commission quite a few review studies to
look into the literature and see if we
do have any conclusive results and and
this is some of the some of the
summaries on this and then I'll come to
the importance of ecosystem services in
this whole context now from a very broad
perspective there is considerable
overlap in geographical terms between
poverty and and biodiversity hotspots or
areas of special interest nonetheless
the specific overlap of valuable
ecosystem services end of poverty on the
sub
national level is much less clear so if
you look at it broadly and on a world
map yes but if you go into detail it
requires much more research and
understanding poor households do depend
disproportionately on biodiversity OS or
ecosystem services both for income and
for insurance against risk very often
directly depend there it's only for the
higher valuable resources that we we
find that richer households usually have
a higher proportion in general terms I
might I might have to say at the outset
that the empirical basis for all these
findings is is quite sketchy so they've
they've looked into this really hundreds
of studies but very few have conclusive
evidence that can actually be
extrapolated but these are the trends
that can be can be generated there so
biodiversity can help lead out of
poverty but it is more important as a
safety net sometimes it's also a poverty
trap because the resources people depend
on require so much important and work
and actually don't offer good
remuneration so there's they stay right
there conservation interventions on the
other hand are off not well designed to
actually help reduce poverty they often
actually crowd out poorer households for
example by requiring formal property
rights that these may not have and the
literature sees quite a potential in
community natural resource management I
don't know if you caught on that first
slide that currently about thirty
percent of Africa's total land area is
under common property so we tend to
think this is an exception and it is in
many countries but in others it is it is
the is one of the most important tenure
forms and if you do
design programs to take this into
account you miss out on quite a
potential they also found that the focus
on cash benefit obscures the potential
of other benefits so that many studies
that look into the settings more deeply
find that biodiversity or wild resources
while food are important risk mitigation
are important safety nets the fact that
someone is involved in a co management
regime which will actually be at least
the first step in securing or in
recognizing his rights there that might
be much more important people than the
actual cash income it generates there
also seems to be evident that at least
in the short run biomass may matter more
to poverty than biodiversity so the
sheer amount of what is being produced
and on a more conceptual level it's the
unclear definition of both biodiversity
and poverty that actually hinders to
establish a clear understanding of the
relationships this is what I'd like to
go into with my next two slides so
breaking down the poverty beyond the
income debate and this has also been
ongoing for ever in spite of the fact
that still most countries measure their
poverty with the poverty line of saying
less than one dollar or less than
something dollars power purchasing
parity per day there is widespread
agreement that poverty comes as a
multi-dimensional phenomenon is not
simply about low incomes it is
multi-dimensional depravation involving
hunger undernutrition dirty drinking
water illiteracy having no access to
health service all the way to social
isolation and exploitation and you can
clearly see that at least the first five
of these have a clear relationship to
ecosystem services especially for people
who are we are
living in in rural settings but in
developing country also in many city
many cities some of these relations are
maintained now beyond these dimensions
and poverty can also be characterized by
different aspects that go start out with
the incidence of poverty taking into
account account how this develops over
space and time or how this is
distributed the intensity of poverty so
are we talking about people to barely
under some minimum level of being able
to provide for themselves or are they
far off such such a position especially
if we talk about situations of
exploitation or or isolation or the not
possibility to to have one's rights
recognized the inequality between the
the poorer parts of population as well
as between better off groups in society
and the poorer ones and finally also
quite decisive for understanding the
mechanisms of poverty the volatility
meaning with what ease can people move
in and out of poverty the same for
biodiversity not going to go into the
details but you all know the three
different levels of diversity that we're
interested in and depending on whether
we look at the composition the structure
or the function of each of these we come
up with quite different types of
indicators so we usually find that
studies look at any one of these aspects
and any one aspect of poverty and that
makes it very very hard to actually
understand causal relationships or to
get into some kind of detailed
understanding of what's actually going
on so I continue with the findings
of course the relationship between
biodiversity in poverty is not the same
as the relationship between biodiversity
conservation in poverty and as pointed
out earlier the design of conservation
measures is is decisive here so our very
limited understanding of the dependence
often also precludes us from finding
solutions that are actually adequate to
take into account how people depend on
use use natural resources or
biodiversity very simple example from a
national park in in India where they
found that in an urban area people were
using this area very much for for
walking in for accessing a more peaceful
and natural setting and finally agreed
to let local people into the park in the
early morning hours without charging any
income and this was particularly for
poorer people a good opportunity to
actually use keep using this while at
the same time the park could generate
income by charging fees to better off
people later on in the day and many
conservation designs part from from the
assumption that it is in the interest of
people to to conserve biodiversity or to
conserve a certain species or the
habitat for a certain species where they
could easily with a stronger focus on
the benefits that it is that this area
is providing to local people get much
more collaboration much more
understanding in a much better targeted
conservation design will come a little
bit into that in the next lecture as
well when we look at some of the cases
there it looks as though the
International and the local levels are
much better studied and understood than
the intermediate ones so there were
plenty of world maps presented with
ecosystem services and coincidence of
hotspots and this and importance etc and
a lot of local case that is of course
but
the more intermediate level situations
of what in this particular legal and
cultural setting is actually important
is actually doable is is actually
causing an issue is much less widespread
and the final conclusion that the
potential of a better understanding of
the underlying causes of both often of
both poverty and biodiversity
conservation thus the potential of a
much greener economy and less
consumption oriented growth would allow
or would might take us much further than
trying to understand the intricacies
between these two aspects okay so from
now our claim against this background is
that ecosystem services might actually
be a much more useful proxy to looking
into this relationship rather than
trying to understand the intricacies of
the diver biodiversity nine field matrix
that I that I showed earlier so some
examples where this is one example from
Sri Lanka where water tank management
for paddy rice so this was a traditional
system of basically dugout ponds where
water was stored in the window wet
season two then serve both for
irrigation but also drinking water and
these were increasingly silting up and
there were more more productive
technologies available for paddy
irrigation and an ongoing debate should
the water better be used for hydropower
or other uses upstream and then the
first thing they did was try and analyze
the local situation and commissioned
evaluation study mrs. Lucey Emerton and
her team and
they decided to look only at the
provisioning services and interestingly
enough they found that if we look at
what paddy cultivation error at the
total value per unit of water tank area
that the paddy cultivation is some six
percent of it only that most of the
values actually with the domestic use
with with livestock with fisheries and
if if we look even at the most simplest
distribution indicator so the percentage
of households that actually benefits
from it we can also see that it's a
small minority concerned with the paddy
and making use of that and a much larger
proportion for the domestic water or the
fisheries for that matter so this
focusing only or looking at the issue
from the perspective of paddy irrigation
would have lost out on ninety-five
percent of the value and of the local
use and of 93 and a high percentage of
the people that are benefiting from it
so sometimes even this very first step
of identifying who benefits and to what
extent already takes us quite a ways in
understanding in understanding the
setting
yeah I think there was they used they
used market values wherever they had
them and and operated with proxies I
think especially for the domestic water
they calculated the value of the time
required to get it out of other sources
if I remember correctly but most of
these products have market values in the
setting I'm not quite sure whether the
lotus flowers might be a very religious
use only then it was a participatory
exercise where they involve the
villagers so they might have just
discussed a value with them on those i
am not sure on all the details
okay so basically what we're suggesting
this chap that was also on the on the
classes system is that it makes
biosystem services are good indicator
and a good proxy and a good way of
understanding dependence and
relationship and suggest a way of
assessing these in a poverty's sensitive
way so of course this adds on to the
burden of all the things to take into
account while while doing an assessment
but if you use it as a checklist in the
back of your mind just to see okay what
might be important I think it's already
a useful tool so what ecosystem services
are in the area and typically wild food
raw materials non-timber forest products
get get overlooked what regulating
services are decisive for rural
population and lookout for seasonal
changes seasonal and also between years
yes
yeah trying to think if we have an
example bioprospecting is definitely an
issue in many in many oil several
countries to put it that way in meaning
quite a few of these countries like the
Philippines local oil not local but
national people are well able to do
these inventories themselves so it's not
national naturally what not always
someone coming in from the outside doing
it I'm I'm not aware of this having been
an issue in in such a study beginning
with the fact that there aren't that
many studies at least we did a very
active search for the tube cases and
didn't come up with a terribly
impressive pressing number I know it is
always an area it has often been an
issue when people want to take specimens
out of the country then then the virus
prospecting alarm bells ring quickly and
I think rightly so but I'm not aware of
of an ecosystem service assessment
causing this and particularly if you
look at the village level and look
coarsely over what are people using this
for and why is this important to them
so then the question we also discover
all looked into briefly last time which
ecosystem aspects or which parts of an
ecosystem are or may be critical for
system stability as far as you can judge
that without profound ecological
knowledge unaware that that is not
always easy then the question which
groups benefit to what extent from
different ecosystem services and yes
even if you only look at what percentage
of households actually benefit from
something it is a rough indicator if you
look at the special coincidence of poor
people and the availability of certain
ecosystem services if you are not able
to go into more detail but of course as
we saw with the poverty there there are
many aspects in in describing this
dependency which is then the next point
an important point here is the is this
accessibility of substitutes especially
to poorer households so who is able to
who depends on these resources without
being able to substitute them and of
course the question of who holds what
rights and how are these rights being
recognized so I'll put people in a
position to actually enforce these
rights what conflicts over rights or
over actual availability and use our
manifest or imminent and finally under
which regime can the service is best be
provided in a specific setting and what
options are there to to adapt this this
regime in order to be more poverty
sensitive or more effective in terms of
maintaining ecosystem services okay and
that's what I prepared for today is in
order to have some time for discussion
left I have some more slides but
come to those if that's if they touch
subjects of your concern